n'utilise jamais le mot intelligent avec moi
n'utilise jamais ce mot
oh donne moi ton parce que tu sais ce qu'il n'y a
rien d'intelligent en toi joe
quarante sept ans tu as fait ça ce qui
se passe
il n'y a plus de question veux tu
écouter qui est  sur votre liste vous savez que
c'est à vous
messieurs voici le problème le fait est
que tout ce qu'il dit jusqu'à présent n'est
qu'un mensonge
je ne suis pas là pour dénoncer ses mensonges
tout le monde sait qu'il est un menteur mais vous
je veux juste qu'il vous le dise
laissez-moi vous arrêter une seconde joe
juste une seconde laissez-le finir
monsieur il ne sait pas comment faire ça
vous êtes le pire président que l'amérique
ait jamais eu
laissez moi laissez moi juste vous dire joe j'ai
fait plus
en 47 mois j'ai fait plus que tu n'as
fait en 47 ans
continue de japper mec les gens te comprennent
nous avons les robes nous avons les masques nous avons
fait les ventilateurs tu n'aurais pas
fait de ventilateurs d'ailleurs il a une
réponse  pour les ouragans, il a dit que
nous devrions peut-être larguer une arme nucléaire sur
eux, je n'ai peut-être jamais dit que
je porte des masques en cas de besoin en cas de besoin je
porte un masque
d'accord laissez-moi demander je n'ai pas à le faire je ne
porte pas de gâchis comme lui à chaque fois  vous le voyez
il a un masque
40 000 personnes par jour contractent la
convoitise
en plus de cela environ entre 750
et un millier de personnes aujourd'hui meurent
quand on lui a présenté ce nombre
il a dit c'est ce que c'est
bien c'est ce que c'est parce que  tu es
qui tu es c'est
pourquoi il s'interface avec cela
aurait laissé deux jours certainement tu
aurais perdu tous les problèmes qu'il
sait comprendre mardi tu
dois avoir l'air très chanceux stupide
je ne jouerais jamais je jouerais vas-
y
monsieur le vice-président a répondu  son q sa
dernière question
la dernière question est je ne me souviens plus
laquelle de toutes est la rage
j'ai un peu de mal moi-même